foreign
's in Indianapolis whoops that's wrong
let me try it again Kevin's in
Indianapolis to uh start off this hour
hi Kevin how are you
hey Dave I'm doing well how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
well uh got a question my wife and I
have been talking for about a week or
two now we are trying to get some stuff
underway to start saving up for a
mortgage on our house uh back story is
we're about one quarter smart three
quarters dumb we were one quarter smart
off by living off of uh thirty thousand
dollar a year income for on her income
so I could pay my way through Masters
School three-quarter done we needed a
reliable car so I fell into that trap
and I bought a car years ago
um where we're at now is we owe about 21
800 left on the car
in one savings area we have about 19 000
in another savings area have about five
thousand we are torn between being
highly aggressive with that nineteen
thousand and being mildly aggressive
because we do have a one-year-old and
we're both kind of like you know do we
go for the full 19 or do you go a little
less wondering what your advice would be
on that
did you graduate
yeah yeah graduated got a double year
income right now I bring in them 125
gross 125.
gross yes okay and she's still working
and she makes 30.
yeah so we have 150 000 household income
yeah a twenty one thousand dollar car
debt
and 24 000 in your accounts
yes
and what are the what are they each
saved and what's the 19 000 in
uh it's over in a in Capital One it's
just over there sitting in a a high
performance CD or high performance
savings okay and then the other five is
where
it's just in our mutual Bank account
okay gotcha gotcha good the five the
five is our kind of
um
hour three months we're just starting to
look at your guys's stuff a little bit
and when we're looking at our numbers
the five is kind of our about five
months
um savings we have a thousand emergency
but the five is there the 5000 is about
a four or five months yeah yeah so what
what happened Kevin was when I was your
age I went broke and lost everything
Rachel was a baby and we couldn't pay
the light bill
and so from that experience I started
studying what is the fastest
right way to build wealth because I had
built wealth
the wrong way
and that's why I lost everything too
much debt
and in studying that and in studying
people who had built wealth I pretty
quickly discovered that the fact that
the people who build wealth not the
middle class and not the people who
wander around in a fog
with an opinion
but the people who had actually become
millionaires the vast majority of them
realize that their most powerful wealth
building tool was their income
none of them get rich on a high-yield
savings account
savings account will not by Def cannot
mathematically by definition make you
rich because you're making three or four
percent
yeah
inflation is nine okay right yeah so
you're going backward all right period
so the bottom line is this the ones that
built wealth were the ones that got out
of debt and avoided that that put us on
the Journey of at Ramsey 30 years ago of
showing people how to get out of debt so
that they can build wealth more reliably
so that they can change their family
tree so that they can be outrageously
generous okay
so that's the premise on which we answer
all of these questions we want to take
you down that path and never in the
history of man has someone keeping a
twenty one thousand dollar car loan
around like it's a pet been a method of
Building Wealth
think about it we were we were we were
really aggressive with it to get to
start so it was sixty thousand dollars
total I paid 40 in two years and now
we're looking at it as when we do when
we say let's just say out loud that that
purchase was stupid
well yeah it was way out of your budget
you said that was the 25 not smart I'm
agreeing with you okay I've done Dumber
I've done Dumber I've done Dumber But
but so you know all of that's going to
lead us to a pretty simple answer
yeah which Kevin is is to pay it off
today and then you're gonna have three
thousand dollars
left as a buffer for your starter or
your emergency fund and baby step three
which is your three to six months of
expenses but you make a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year you should
be able to put several thousand dollars
a month in that account and so we're not
going to be at 3 000 but for 30 seconds
the end of the next month you should be
at six or eight thousand then into the
next month you should be ten or twelve
thousand dollars so we're not walking
around with a one-year-old with
absolutely no money as a way of life
it's just a momentary thing here by
Christmas you ought to have a big old
pile of money man
and that's that's where we're at where
we're both when we talk about it we both
see the like you're saying Dave with the
get aggressive and then four months you
have this and we're both looking at the
one-year-old who does have some medical
appointments coming up going should we
be just slightly safer and span it out
over a minute we're not gonna have a
medical appointment unless the child has
medical issues today you're not going to
have a one-year-old medical appointment
that is going to take more than three
thousand dollars
okay unless he has some kind of unless
he's struggling with something but if
he's going in for standard
checkups you know it's a couple hundred
bucks dude and you make 150 000 a year
I think you can handle it
he'll be aggressive with it highly
aggressive the reason would be that
that's the fastest right way for you to
build wealth get that emergency fund in
place a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and then
with no payments at all now we save for
that house like crazy
and you can do it man I mean you just
you lean in on a budget yeah and I think
Kevin too one of the the mindset shifts
that is important for you guys just to
say out loud with you and your wife is
like okay where we are today we don't
like it we don't like having we had a
sixty thousand dollar car loan now we've
done you know we've we've taken it down
to 21 000 we have some money here we
have some money there obviously
something is stirring in you guys that
you're not content with where you are
financially you know there's something
in you that's like man there could be a
better way which is why you picked up
your phone and called the show right I
mean like there are you walking into the
bear cage
they're Named Dave bear named Dave uh
but but so so my challenge to you Kevin
would be like to be do something
different try this way what we're saying
and again it's not gonna put you back
financially at all you guys have a great
income you're gonna be okay and there's
gonna be natural fear natural hesitation
to do something that feels a little
different but what you guys have been
doing if you keep doing the same thing
you're not going to be happy with your
results so you have to do something
different doing something different is
uncomfortable but push in even if it's
even if you're scared and comfortable
because you're gonna be okay you're
gonna be okay you're gonna be fine if
you pay attention and play through
good stuff